it is the first ever f-16 fighting
falcon converted locally into a
thunderbird jet
christian kosarus joining us live in our
newsroom with more on this
transformation and when we can expect to
see it in the sky
well guys i'm sure many already spotted
the new jet when it flew around southern
nevada for the very first time
on may 5th and i'm told it was out
flying again
yesterday now take a look here on your
screen these are images from the f616
fighting falcon that went under an
in-house local conversion
to a thunderbird show ready jet there
you can see the time lapse video of the
crew working hard to modify the aircraft
now some of the changes included
included rewiring removal of the jet
fuel doors and installing new components
in accordance with the blueprints now we
are told a conversion normally takes
about a year
and it's done at hill air force base in
utah in this case the falcon was
modified
locally in seven months saving time
money and manpower
thanks to the airmen and the help of the
nellis air force base folks
the major modification when it becomes a
thunderbird as far as weapon system
is the removal of the gatling gun system
that 20-millimeter system
however aircraft retain all the other
capabilities
to eventually go back to having
a combat capability if that's required
in the future
so we're told resources for a conversion
are limited so the local team decided to
take on the challenge and they completed
the task
in less than a year the longest process
they say was the paint job
so about a dozen conversion conversions
happen each year we're told
f-16s are going through some
modifications and upgrades right now so
you can expect to see the jet
number eight in the sky in future shows
christian gossip is 8 news now